- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La séance est
ouverte. L'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par madame Sandrine
Rousseau.
- Sandrine Rousseau: Avant de
débuter cette question au
gouvernement, je souhaiterais que
notre assemblée rende hommage à
l'inspecteur des impôts tué hier
lors d'un contrôle dans le
Pas-de-Calais.
Nous assurons ses proches de notre
soutien mais aussi de notre
clairvoyance sur le rôle important
et complexe que jouent
actuellement les agents du service
public qui se trouvent en première
ligne de la crise sociale et de la
montée des tensions au sein de
notre société.
Ils sont nombreux à faire part de
la montée de la violence à
laquelle ils doivent faire face,
dans un contexte de fragilisation
permanente de nos moyens et
crédits.
Nous demandons de respecter une
minute de silence.
On demande une minute de silence,
madame la présidente.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: J'ai bien
entendu, madame Rousseau.
Effectivement, après cet acte
absolument tragique, je pense que
l'Assemblée nationale peut
s'associer à la douleur de la
famille et au respect que nous
devons à tous ces serviteurs de
l'Etat qui agissent au quotidien
pour notre pays.
...
Je vous remercie.
- Sandrine Rousseau: Ma question
s'adresse désormais au ministre de
l'Intérieur, Gérald Darmanin.
Monsieur le ministre, 300
gendarmes, policiers et militaires
français sont affectés à la
sécurité de la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar.
Ces personnels français vont-ils
permettre aux personnes LGBTQIA+
de vivre sur place en sécurité?
Pourront-ils brandir un drapeau
aux couleurs LGBT?
Pourront-ils s'embrasser dans la
rue?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci de vous
installer dans le calme, s'il vous
plaît.
- Sandrine Rousseau: Pourront-ils
demander l'intervention des forces
de l'ordre en cas de
discrimination dans l'accès aux
chambres d'hôtel?
L'affirmation d'une sexualité LGBT
est illégale, au Qatar, mais peut
conduire aussi à de
l'emprisonnement et à la peine de
mort pour les personnes de
confession musulmane.
Selon le Guardian, les autorités
ne se contenteraient pas d'arrêter
et violenter les personnes LGBT,
elles auraient mis en place un
système sordide, visant à les
obliger à dénoncer d'autres
personnes LGBT pour échapper aux
tortures.
La FIFA a interdit explicitement
le port du brassard arc-en-ciel,
ce qui n'annonce rien de bon.
Ma question est simple: la
garantie des droits des personnes
LGBT fait-elle partie des missions
confiées aux forces de l'ordre
française?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Madame la
députée Sandrine Rousseau, il y a
225 personnels du ministère de
l'Intérieur en ce moment à Doha et
au Qatar pour plusieurs raisons.
D'abord, c'est pour s'occuper de
nos ressortissants, 20.000
Français, qui vont pouvoir
assister aux matches de la Coupe
du Monde de football.
Ces policiers et gendarmes sont là
pour les accompagner, pour
retrouver les documents d'identité
et pour déposer plainte si jamais
il y avait des difficultés au
Qatar.
Ils sont également là dans le
cadre de la coopération que nous
avons dans les grands événements
sportifs en lien avec nos
industriels.
C'est notamment les gendarmes
français qui ont la politique
anti-drones de la Coupe du Monde
de football.
Ils protègent l'intégralité des
sites aériens des stades de
football du Qatar ou de grandes
équipes de football comme l'équipe
de France.
Cela se fait en lien avec des
entreprises françaises.
La troisième raison pour laquelle
les gendarmes et policiers
français sont sur place, c'est la
formation qu'ils ont pu avoir sur
les motocyclistes qui
accompagnaient les délégations.
Quatrième sujet, le GIGN est là
pour intervenir et pour protéger
l'équipe de France de football ou
ses supporters en cas d'attaque
contre nos intérêts.
En aucun cas les policiers et
gendarmes français ne font du
maintien de l'ordre au Qatar.
En aucun cas ils ne sont en
contact avec la police du Qatar
pour appliquer les lois du Qatar.
Ils sont là pour protéger nos
concitoyens et nous aider à mieux
organiser la Coupe du Monde de
rugby et les Jeux Olympiques.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame
Rousseau?
- Sandrine Rousseau: Vous n'avez
pas du tout répondu à la question.
Est-ce qu'ils les protégeront en
cas de gestes d'homophobie dans
les rues du Qatar?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Véronique Riotton.
- Véronique Riotton: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes, de la Diversité et de
l'Egalité des chances, ainsi qu'à
monsieur le ministre de
l'Education nationale et de la
Jeunesse.
Vendredi prochain, nous serons le
25 novembre, journée mondiale de
mobilisation pour l'éradication
des violences faites aux femmes.
Le président de la République a
choisi de faire de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes la grande
cause de son quinquennat, et ce
pour la seconde fois consécutive.
La lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes est le premier
pilier de cette grande cause.
Depuis 2017, cette lutte a fait
l'objet d'un travail soutenu: le
Grenelle des violences conjugales
nous a permis d'avancer
concrètement, avec 80% de places
d'hébergement en plus, une
multiplication par 2 du budget du
ministère de l'Education et de
l'Egalité entre les femmes et les
hommes, et surtout, des hommes et
des femmes, policiers et
gendarmes, mieux formés.
Nous savons cependant que les
violences perpétrées sur les
femmes ne se cantonnent pas à
l'intimité des foyers.
Ces violences sont présentes dans
toutes les sphères de notre
société, au niveau politique, dans
la rue, dans le sport, au travail.
Avec le développement des outils
numériques, de nouvelles formes de
violences se sont développées.
Je pense aux violences faites aux
femmes sur Internet, les
cyberviolence.
Suite aux confinements,
l'association de protection des
mineurs sur Internet E-enfance
comptabilise une hausse de 60% de
ces violences.
Pour lutter efficacement contre
toutes ces formes de violence, ce
combat nécessite l'engagement de
tous, hommes comme femmes, de
toutes les générations.
Nous devons éduquer chacune et
chacun à une culture de l'égalité
et de la non-violence dès le plus
jeune âge à l'école afin de
prévenir toutes ces formes de
violence.
Comme le disait Nelson Mandela,
l'éducation est l'arme la plus
puissante pour changer le monde.
Madame la ministre, pouvez-vous
nous préciser les actions que vous
prévoyez en la matière?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Isabelle Rome.
- Isabelle Rome: Madame la députée
et présidente Riotton, vous l'avez
rappelé, depuis 2017, le
gouvernement et la majorité se
sont mobilisés comme jamais pour
enrayer le fléau des violences
faites aux femmes.
A la suite du Grenelle des
violences conjugales, quatre lois
ont été votées de manière
transpartisane pour mieux protéger
les victimes.
Le nombre de téléphones grave
danger a été multiplié par 10, le
nombre d'ordonnances de protection
les horaires du 39 19
étendus 24 heures sur 24,
7 jours sur sept.
Le budget qui va être alloué à
l'organisme qui gère le 39 19 va
être de 5,9 millions d'euros grâce
à la majorité et au gouvernement,
soit plus 400% en cinq ans.
Le nombre de places d'hébergement
dédiées aux victimes et à leurs
enfants a également augmenté de
80%.
Pour mieux accompagner les
victimes, la présence des
intervenants sociaux dans les
commissariats et les gendarmeries
sera renforcée.
Ils seront 600 d'ici 2025.
Depuis 2017, ce sont aussi 160.000
policiers et gendarmes formés et
30 centres de prise en charge
ouverts pour les auteurs, afin
d'éviter la récidive.
Vous l'avez dit, les violences
faites aux femmes sont
structurelles.
C'est dès le plus jeune âge qu'il
faut construire une société plus
égalitaire, respectueuse des
femmes.
La culture de l'égalité sera l'un
des axes forts du comité
interministériel à l'égalité
femmes-hommes que la Première
ministre présidera, dès janvier
prochain, que j'aurais à piloter.
Les violences faites aux femmes
sont indignes de notre
civilisation.
C'est sans relâche que le
gouvernement et la majorité mène
le combat contre ce fléau.
- Yaël
Braun-Pivet: La parole est à M.
Emmanuel Fernandes.
- Emmanuel Fernandes: Ma question
s'adresse au ministre du Travail.
C'est en 1945 que votre illustre
prédécesseur prit cette fonction
pour devenir le père de la
Sécurité sociale.
Cruelle ironie qui veut que ce
soit un autre 21 novembre que
votre nom, monsieur Dussopt, soit
à jamais associé à l'une des
réformes les plus antisociales de
l'histoire.
Oui, votre réforme de l'assurance
chômage c'est l'acte 2 de la
guerre qu'Emmanuel Macron mène aux
chômeurs depuis 2017.
Après avoir réduit les droits de
1,15 million de personnes, vous
annonciez hier la baisse de 25% de
la durée d'indemnisation.
En cumulant les économies de cette
réforme, le président des riches
aura repris d'une main 6,6
milliards d'euros par an aux
chômeurs, pour donner de votre
main 1,7 million d'euros par an
aux 100 Français les plus riches
par la suppression de l'ISF et la
flat tax.
Vous faites les poches au peuple,
mais vous gaver vos amis.
Pire, votre injuste mécanisme de
modulation entraînera la double
peine dans les zones du pays où le
chômage continu d'augmenter dès
lors que la moyenne nationale sera
tirée vers le bas grâce aux
régions où l'on embauche.
Pour vous, les chômeurs sont des
fainéants qui profitent de leurs
aides.
Assez de cette insupportable
indécence.
Savez-vous que plus de 40% des
chômeurs sont déjà dans la
pauvreté?
Si malgré ces données factuelles
vous pensez toujours que le
chômage est trop rentable comparé
au fait de retourner bosser,
pourquoi ne pas voter ce jeudi
pour l'augmentation du SMIC à 1600
euros?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à M.
Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Monsieur le
député, hier, j'ai présenté aux
partenaires sociaux les mécanismes
d'indemnisation de l'assurance
chômage.
C'était un engagement du président
de la
République pris pendant la
campagne.
Cette règle s'appuie sur un
principe simple.
Quand les choses vont bien, les
règles doivent être plus
incitatives.
Quand les choses vont mal, elles
doivent être plus protectrices.
Vous avez essayé de tracer un
bilan qui n'est pas la réalité en
matière d'emploi.
Vous avez qualifié le président de
la République avec beaucoup
d'impolitesse, mais vous avez
oublié un certain nombre de
choses.
Vous avez oublié que c'est cette
majorité qui, en cinq ans, a
permis à plus d'un million de
personnes de retrouver le chemin
de l'emploi.
C'est cette majorité qui a mis en
place le plan d'investissement
dans les compétences avec 15
milliards d'euros d'investissement
dans l'insertion.
C'est cette majorité qui met en
place le contrat Engagement jeune,
avec presque 300.000
bénéficiaires, les jeunes sans
emploi et sans formation que l'on
peut accompagner sur le chemin de
l'emploi.
C'est aussi cette majorité qui,
parce qu'elle a augmenté les
crédits consacrés à
l'apprentissage, permet à notre
pays d'avoir aujourd'hui plus de
800.000 apprentis, avec une voie
royale pour l'insertion
professionnelle.
C'est enfin cette majorité qui,
depuis un an, face aux difficultés
de recrutement des entreprises, a
mis en place un plan de réduction
des tensions, qui a permis de
raccompagner vers l'emploi des
centaines de chômeurs de longue
durée.
Cela nous permet de consacrer plus
de moyens à l'insertion.
Notre majorité, c'est celle du
plein emploi.
Vous avez osé parler de mépris
vis-à-vis des chômeurs.
Le seul mépris, c'est le vôtre,
c'est celui qui consiste à
souhaiter que la précarité reste,
parce que la précarité, c'est
votre fonds de commerce!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Il vous reste
trois secondes.
- Emmanuel Fernandes: Vous
détruisez la solidarité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Marietta Karamanli.
- Marietta Karamanli: Merci.
Avant de poser ma question à
monsieur le garde des Sceaux, je
voulais quand même rappeler que le
39 19 a été créé par les
socialistes.
Le gouvernement vient d'annoncer
un plan pour la protection des
enfants et la lutte contre les
violences faites aux enfants.
Si l'intention est bonne, elle ne
doit pas faire oublier l'actuelle
réalité d'une justice sinistrée,
et je ne parle pas que de la
justice pénale mais aussi de la
justice civile.
Il y a un pan entier de la justice
qui est sinistré.
Ce sont les affaires familiales.
Il y a des manifestations et les
protestations des magistrats à
l'heure où nous parlons.
Ils sont au bord d'un burn-out, de
l'épuisement, entre colère et
amertume.
La famille est certainement ce qui
compte le plus pour les Françaises
et les Français.
Une séparation, la gestion de la
garde des enfants, un changement
dans la situation financière des
époux, ce sont des choses
courantes, qui ont des effets
difficiles.
Au tribunal judiciaire du Mans, le
délai pour obtenir une audience
est de 12 à 15 mois.
Le quotidien, ce sont des séances
à rallonge, les familles
connaissant de nombreuses
difficultés pour divorcer
et obtenir la garde d'enfants,
faute de délais raisonnables et
fragilisés par l'absence de
décision des magistrats fatigués
et des avocats démotivés, devant
expliquer pourquoi il ne se passe
rien.
Il faut donc se préoccuper de la
violence, mais aussi se prémunir
d'aggraver la situation.
Au plan pénal, bon nombre
d'affaires de violences conjugales
sont renvoyées d'une année sur
l'autre.
Le budget de la justice est en
augmentation, et nous avons
recruté.
Néanmoins, il faut des mesures
d'urgence pertinentes et penser
avec les magistrats.
Ma question est simple: que
comptez-vous faire d'exceptionnel
pour que les familles aient droit
à une vraie justice, que les
magistrats évitent le pire pour
leur santé et que les avocats
retrouvent leur efficacité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Eric Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Madame la
députée vous dites, et je vous
entends, que la justice est
sinistrée.
Mais ces murs ont des oreilles,
mais ils ont aussi une mémoire.
Il fut un temps pas si lointain,
vous étiez au pouvoir, où les
augmentations de budget, c'était
1%, et personne à l'époque ne
disait rien.
Vous dites qu'il ne se passe rien.
On va quand même rappeler deux ou
trois choses.
44% d'augmentation du budget
depuis l'élection du président de
la République, ça, c'est nous.
Plus 26% d'augmentation du budget,
c'est nous, madame.
Le plus grand plan d'embauche de
l'histoire de la justice, 750
magistrats, 850 greffiers, 2000
contractuels, c'est nous, madame.
La plus grande promotion de
l'école nationale de la
magistrature, il nous faut des
bâtiments supplémentaires, parce
qu'on ne peut pas écarter les
murs.
Et puis, 1000 euros d'augmentation
mensuelle nette pour les
magistrats, pas un magistrat ne
commencera sa carrière à moins de
3000 euros.
Pour l'urgence, c'est dans
quelques jours les annonces des
états généraux, et vous verrez les
mesures qui seront prises en
matière civile, en matière pénale,
en matière économique et sociale.
Nous ne faisons pas que critiquer.
Nous agissons.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Fabien Di
Filippo.
- Fabien Di Filippo: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame la
députée?
Non.
C'est le ministre qui avait du
temps, madame Karamanli, pas vous.
Monsieur Di Filippo.
Alors on remet le compteur à 0
pour monsieur Di Filippo.
- Fabien Di Filippo: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur.
Nous refusons de voir la France
devenir chaque jour un peu plus
l'eldorado de la clandestinité.
L'accueil du bateau Ocean Viking
et ses 234 migrants a finalement
donné lieu au fiasco judiciaire et
sécuritaire inévitable et annoncé.
Sur votre engagement d'éloignement
immédiat des déboutés du droit
d'asile, et sur le contrôle des
mineurs isolés dont 60% ont fugué,
vous êtes sur un échec.
Emmanuel Macron déclarait pourtant
en 2018 à propos de l'Aquarius que
si la France devenait le port
d'accueil des bateaux qui partent
d'Afrique, ce serait insoutenable
et que les bons sentiments faciles
feraient juste basculer le pays
dans les extrêmes.
Il faut un message limpide et plus
ferme.
Vous aviez entamé à votre prise de
fonction une tournée de plusieurs
pays pour négocier des
laissez-passer consulaires et
augmenter l'exécution des
expulsions, dont 9 sur 10 restent
toujours lettre morte.
Mais l'octroi des visas réguliers
et l'aide au développement doivent
être désormais conditionnés à la
délivrance systématique des
laissez-passer consulaires pour
éloigner les
clandestins.
La France doit soutenir
l'ordonnance d'accueil des
migrants.
Les questions sont directes.
Ecouterez-vous enfin des
propositions de la droite
républicaine pour bâtir une
politique migratoire ferme et
réaliste, assurant la sécurité de
nos concitoyens, l'éloignement de
ceux qui volent nos lois et
permettent l'intégration des
personnes qui mériteraient d'être
accueillies?
Ou alors, attendrez-vous de
quitter le gouvernement pour
dénoncer l'hypocrisie laxiste du
pouvoir et le dévoiement des
procédures migratoires qui
affaiblissent notre république?
- Gérald Darmanin: Monsieur le
député Fabien Di Filippo, votre
question est importante.
Elle touche à la politique
migratoire de notre pays.
Nous aurons bientôt l'occasion,
dans ce même hémicycle, le 6
décembre prochain, d'entendre les
propositions du groupe Les
Républicains sur la politique
migratoire.
Un débat est souhaité ici et au
Sénat.
Il y aura ensuite un texte très
important que j'ai eu l'honneur de
présenter avec Olivier Dussopt,
déjà, en préfiguration de nos
discussions, qui sera ensuite
transmis au Conseil d'Etat, après
les débats parlementaires, après
des consultations politiques
également.
J'ai proposé à votre groupe comme
à tous les groupes de venir
discuter avec nous de ce texte
pour que nous puissions construire
ensemble.
Le texte sera discuté à partir de
janvier, au Sénat, puis sans doute
en avril, dans cet hémicycle.
Nous en tirerons des conclusions
de l'Ocean Viking.
Nous devons aussi nous questionner
sur les moyens que nous devons
mettre pour lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine tout en
encourageant une immigration de
travail qui est souhaitée par
beaucoup de Français.
Nous voulons dire aussi que
l'aspect européen est très
important.
Dès le mois de juin prochain, un
premier système d'entrée et de
sortie de Schengen aura lieu dans
toute l'Europe, et c'est grâce à
la présidence française de l'Union
Européenne.
Dès vendredi après-midi, à la
demande de la France, une réunion
extraordinaire des ministres de
l'Intérieur de l'Union Européenne
prendra en compte la proposition
de la Commission européenne rendue
publique hier qui est en tout
point conforme à la position de la
France: le droit de la mer doit
être respecté par tous les pays,
l'accueil des étrangers doit être
fait dans des bonnes conditions
sur le sol européen, et les pays
de départ doivent être
responsabilisés, notamment en
conditionnant les aides au
développement.
- Fabien Di Filippo: En 2018,
Gérard Collomb avait balayé toutes
nos propositions.
C'est le dernier rendez-vous de
fermeté, il faudra le saisir.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Philippe Pradal.
- Philippe Pradal: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Justice, au
sujet du mouvement des magistrats
qui a lieu aujourd'hui.
Les syndicats ont lancé un appel à
la grève, un an après la
publication de la tribune des
3000, qui vous alertait sur le
manque de moyens chronique subi
par les magistrats, l'ensemble des
professionnels de la justice et
les justiciables.
Cette tribune faisait suite au
malheureux suicide d'une
magistrate dont nous saluons la
mémoire.
Nous saluons la mémoire d'une
autre magistrate décédée dans des
circonstances obscures en octobre
dernier.
Le quinquennat précédent a permis
de voter plusieurs réformes
ambitieuses.
La sécurité et la justice restent
des priorités au service de nos
concitoyens.
La mission justice dont le budget
a pu être débattu et voté en
commission et en séance publique.
Depuis plusieurs années, les
crédits de votre ministère sont en
augmentation, en accord avec la
politique souhaitée par le
président de la République.
Or, certaines expressions
syndicales affirment que, depuis
un an, rien n'a été fait.
Ainsi, je vous demande d'exposer
devant la représentation nationale
les mesures prises en faveur d'un
meilleur fonctionnement de la
justice depuis un an et également
de dire en quoi les crédits
adoptés dans le projet de loi de
finances 2023 permettront
d'améliorer les conditions du
rendu de la justice dans notre
pays.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Eric Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Monsieur le
député Pradal,
d'abord, je voudrais me joindre à
l'hommage s'agissant du décès que
vous avez évoqué.
J'ai une pensée particulière pour
elle et pour sa famille.
Je ne vais pas reprendre les
chiffres que j'ai donnés dans le
cadre d'une précédente question
qui m'a été posée par madame
Karamanli, mais je voudrais dire
que nous n'avons pas à rougir de
ce que nous avons fait, et nous
avons réparé 30 ans d'abandon
humain, politique et budgétaire.
Vous le savez, parce que vous êtes
un député sérieux, les choses ne
se font pas en un claquement de
doigt.
Pour l'avenir, nous allons
présenter une loi de
programmation.
Ce n'est pas une rumeur.
Madame la Première ministre
l'avait déjà annoncé.
C'est un grand plan d'embauche, un
deuxième grand plan d'embauche:
1500 magistrats, 1500 greffiers,
10.000 personnels au total, dont
les contractuels, contractuels
dont je rappelle qu'ils ont
précédemment permis de réduire les
stocks, notamment des affaires
civiles de plus de 25%.
Au-delà de ça, je présenterai dans
quelques jours les états généraux
de la justice, et de grandes
mesures de simplification en
matière civile: aller vers
l'amiable.
S'agissant du mouvement des
magistrats, très franchement,
j'aurais préféré que tous les
magistrats et syndicats de
magistrats viennent lors des
concertations que j'ai organisées
dans le cadre des états généraux.
Certains sont venus, d'autres
n'ont pas voulu, et j'ai affirmé à
l'époque qu'une porte ouverte qui
n'était pas franchie n'était pas
une porte fermée.
Ils ont choisi un autre mode
d'expression.
Ca les regarde.
Je respecte cette liberté.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Mathilde Paris.
- Mathilde Paris: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur.
Le 10 novembre, l'exécutif a pris
la décision d'accueillir le bateau
Ocean Viking sur la base militaire
de Toulon.
Au journal de 20h, vous avez
déclaré que les 234 migrants "ne
pourront pas sortir du centre
administratif".
Pourtant, à peine deux semaines
plus tard, la situation est
catastrophique.
La quasi-totalité de ces migrants
a été libérée.
Sur les 44 mineurs pris en charge,
26 ont fui.
Sur les 123 qui s'étaient vu
refuser l'entrée sur le
territoire, une centaine a malgré
tout été laissée libre de quitter
la zone d'attente sur décision de
justice.
Au fond, ce fiasco illustre
l'impuissance de votre
gouvernement.
Impuissance à maîtriser les flux
migratoires, impuissance face à
l'oppression des ONG d'extrême
gauche, complices de passeurs,
impuissance à réformer la
politique migratoire pour la
rendre plus dissuasive.
Il est temps de reprendre le
contrôle.
Je doute de l'efficacité de la
prochaine loi immigration.
Vous avez annoncé que vous
profiterez de ce texte pour créer
une filière d'immigration pour les
métiers en tension.
Concernant les propos à l'instant
de LR, il y a les paroles et les
actes.
Dans ma région, le vote LR vote
chaque année des subventions à SOS
Méditerranée.
Loin du laxisme de votre
gouvernement, le Rassemblement
National a des solutions et elles
sont plébiscitées par les
Français.
Ma question est très simple.
Qu'attendez-vous pour donner la
parole au peuple en organisant un
référendum sur l'immigration?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Gérald Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Madame la
députée Paris, permettez-moi de
vous corriger: ce n'est pas
l'exécutif qui a accueilli ce
bateau, c'est notre humanité.
Et permettez-moi de vous dire que
je suis très étonné de la part de
députés qui se disent nationaux et
compatriotes que vous préférez
attaquer le gouvernement plutôt
que vos amis italiens.
Finalement, vous êtes très
internationaliste.
Vous préférez attaquer les
policiers français, les
justiciables français qui ont
considéré qu'il fallait accueillir
ces personnes, et notamment 44
enfants.
En effet, vous n'êtes pas toujours
patriotes lorsqu'il faut vous
allier avec les ennemis de ceux
qui attaquent la France en ce
moment.
Madame, nous avons respecté le
droit international.
Nous avons accueilli ce bateau.
Le ministre de l'Intérieur
respecte l'Etat de droit et le
droit tout court.
Le juge des libertés de la
détention a permis de sortir ces
personnes de cette zone d'attente.
Nous devons changer de droit.
C'est justement ce que nous allons
faire dans la loi immigration.
Nous verrons quelle sera votre
position, parce que si c'est la
même critique que lors du texte
que j'ai présenté sur la
sécurité...
Vous nous avez critiqué pendant
trois mois avant de voter notre
texte en catimini.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame Paris?
- Mathilde Paris: On peut faire
preuve d'humanité mais aussi de
fermeté.
C'est ce que nous demandons, pas
autre chose.
Par ailleurs, les Français ont le
droit d'être consultés sur un
sujet aussi grave.
C'est ce que nous vous demandons.
Alors ne caricaturez pas le débat.
- Gérald Darmanin : Il n'y a pas
d'humanité quand des enfants sont
à bord.
Il n'y a pas d'humanité lorsqu'on
a ce genre de position.
J'ai eu l'occasion de le dire,
vous ne souhaitez pas entendre ce
que fait le gouvernement français.
Il respecte le droit
international.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci,
monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Loïc
Prud'homme.
- Loïc Prud'homme: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres, l'inflation dépasse à
ce jour 6%.
Mais sur les denrées alimentaires,
c'est au minimum 12%.
Le contenu de nos assiettes
n'arrive pas d'Ukraine.
C'est à cause de la spéculation...
C'est la spéculation qui est
responsable de cette situation.
Dans ce contexte, plus de la
moitié des communes ont augmenté
les tarifs des cantines scolaires
de 5% à 10%.
D'autres prennent sur leurs
ressources propres pour maintenir
des tarifs accessibles.
Les collectivités sont prises
entre le marteau et l'enclume.
D'un côté, l'augmentation des prix
de l'alimentation.
De l'autre, les familles impactées
par l'inflation.
Cette réalité, ce quotidien, votre
gouvernement le regarde les bras
ballants, sans prendre une seule
mesure de soutien et en continuant
à pressurer les finances des
communes.
Il y a une baisse de la part des
produits locaux, bios et de
qualité, une baisse des quantités
servies, un choix entre le fromage
et le dessert.
Il y a un renoncement à ce qui est
souvent le seul repas équilibré de
la journée, pour les enfants
fragiles.
A quand la cantine scolaire
gratuite?
Alors que les files s'allongent
devant les aides alimentaires,
cette crise des cantines scolaires
est moins visible.
Allez-vous continuer à faire comme
si elle n'existait pas?
Allez-vous débloquer en urgence
600 millions d'euros dans les
collectivités locales, pour que
nos enfants puissent manger
correctement?
Allez-vous encore dire aux
Français qu'ils doivent se serrer
la ceinture, mais cette fois, au
sens propre, quand d'autres sont
obèses de leurs superprofits?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Caroline
Cayeux, ministre déléguée chargée
des Collectivités territoriales.
- Caroline Cayeux: Merci.
Oui, le gouvernement soutient les
collectivités territoriales.
Il les soutient, face aux prix de
l'énergie, à l'inflation, aux
nombreux défis qui les attendent.
Le PLF adopté par l'Assemblée est
un PLF en faveur des
collectivités.
Concernant les cantines scolaires,
que vous évoquez, je tiens à vous
rappeler que c'est une compétence
des communes et qu'elles les
gèrent, et elles ont le choix de
leur mode de gestion.
Je voudrais vous dire que le
gouvernement a mis en place des
dispositifs ciblés, dès le PLF,
pour les communes fragiles.
Nous avons pris en compte ces
coûts supplémentaires, liés à ces
dépenses.
Les services locaux de
restauration verront leurs
dépenses énergétiques soutenues à
travers différents dispositifs, à
l'attention des collectivités,
qu'il s'agisse du bouclier
tarifaire ou de l'amortisseur
électrique.
Nous poursuivrons nos actions en
faveur de la cantine.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur Michel
Lauzzana pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Michel Lauzzana: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
François Braun, ministre de la
Santé et de la Prévention.
"Papa, pourquoi tu te laisses
pousser la moustache?"
Voici la question d'un jeune
citoyen à son papa.
Depuis le mois de novembre, des
dizaines de milliers de Français
se laissent pousser la moustache
dans le cadre du mouvement
Movember qui prend de l'ampleur
dans le milieu du rugby en
particulier.
Ce mois est dédié à la
sensibilisation de l'opinion
publique au cancer masculin, pour
briser les tabous encore nombreux
chez les hommes.
En France, deux hommes meurent
chaque jour d'un cancer masculin.
Ils représentent 52% des cancers
diagnostiqués, mais les hommes
sont moins nombreux que les femmes
à participer aux dépistages.
Ils ont peur, ils ont un sentiment
de gêne ou de honte.
Je salue votre engagement en
faveur de la prévention, en
particulier dans le PLFSS de 2023.
Je salue la mobilisation
exemplaire des associations et
bénévoles engagés sur l'ensemble
du territoire, à travers des
manifestations locales et des
campagnes de prévention pour
informer les hommes sur le
dépistage.
Mais les tabous ne sont pas encore
brisés dans l'opinion publique.
Nous devons poursuivre nos
actions.
Diagnostiqués tôt, les cancers
masculins se soignent dans la
grande majorité des cas.
Pouvez-vous nous donner votre
stratégie pour poursuivre le
travail de sensibilisation, afin
de mettre un terme aux tabous des
hommes face au cancer masculin?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun.
- François Braun: Merci.
Madame la présidente, mesdames et
messieurs les députés, monsieur le
député Michel Lauzzana, je vous
remercie d'aborder un sujet qui
m'est particulièrement cher, celui
de la prévention.
C'est le meilleur moyen
d'améliorer la santé de nos
concitoyens.
C'est un moyen pour faire des
économies dans la santé.
40% des cancers que nous
diagnostiquons chaque année sont
liés à notre mode de vie.
Ils sont évitables.
C'est un enjeu majeur pour notre
société.
Je salue moi aussi le mouvement
Movember, sur le dépistage du
cancer de la prostate.
Je tiens à saluer et à rappeler à
cette Assemblée que le mois de
novembre est également le mois
sans tabac.
Il conviendrait là aussi de faire
un effort sur ce facteur de risque
qui entraîne des cancers
multiples.
La prévention des cancers
masculins est insuffisamment
développée.
Pourtant, les outils existent.
On peut se faire dépister à partir
de 50 ans du cancer colo-rectal et
à partir de 55 ans du cancer de la
prostate.
Le gouvernement avance pour faire
de notre société une société de
prévention.
Les rendez-vous de prévention aux
âges clés de la vie font partie
des mesures prises par le
gouvernement.
Concernant ces rendez-vous de
prévention, deux enjeux majeurs:
aller chercher les personnes les
plus loin du soin et proposer des
parcours de prévention.
La prévention, c'est prendre soin
de soi.
Je suis confiant.
Nous allons réussir à transformer
notre société vers une société de
prévention.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Florence
Goulet pour le groupe
Rassemblement National.
- Florence Goulet: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'Economie et des
Finances et de la Souveraineté
industrielle et numérique.
12% pour l'alimentation, 17% pour
les produits frais, voilà la
réalité qu'affrontent les familles
françaises alors que les salaires
peinent à augmenter de 4%.
Ces chiffres alarmants cachent de
grandes disparités.
Les huiles alimentaires ont
augmenté de 60%, les pâtes, le
lait, les oeufs, également.
Le dirigeant d'une enseigne de
grande distribution a annoncé ce
matin qu'il refusait de mettre en
rayon des produits de base devenus
si chers que la plupart des
Français ne pouvaient les acheter.
Comment accepter une situation
indigne d'une grande puissance
agricole comme la France,
désormais incapable d'assurer
l'alimentation saine et abordable
de ses habitants?
Marine Le Pen a alerté, dès
septembre 2021, avant la guerre en
Ukraine, sur la gravité de
l'inflation alimentaire, mais
aussi sur sa durée dans le temps.
Pendant des mois, vous avez
annoncé que la France avait
dépassé le pic d'inflation pour
justifier votre passivité.
Aux dernières élections, vous avez
promis un chèque alimentation, que
vous avez finalement enterré.
Quand allez-vous appliquer la
seule mesure concrète pour
soulager les Français: la baisse à
0% de la TVA sur un panier de
produits d'alimentation et
d'hygiène, avec un strict contrôle
de la répercussion sur la baisse
des prix?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Bruno Le
Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
avant de répondre à la députée du
Rassemblement National, je
voudrais m'associer à l'hommage
qui a été rendu à l'agent de la
Direction générale des finances
publiques qui a été assassiné à
côté d'Arras, il y a quelques
heures.
Je voudrais dire à tous les agents
de la DGFIP à tous les agents qui
sont au contact direct du terrain,
tout mon soutien, ma
reconnaissance, et toute l'amitié
de la République et de la nation
française que vous représentez
ici.
Applaudissements
Merci à toutes et à tous.
Bien entendu que l'inflation des
produits alimentaires pèse
durement sur tous nos
compatriotes.
Nous avons anticipé l'augmentation
des prix.
Vous parliez des propositions
faites par la présidente Marine Le
Pen il y a quelques mois.
Je rappelle que cette majorité, la
seule, en Europe, a pris la
décision de protéger nos
compatriotes contre l'explosion
des prix du gaz et de
l'électricité.
Je rappelle que la France, la
première, est la seule en Europe à
avoir engagé un budget pour
protéger nos compatriotes de
l'augmentation des prix.
C'est grâce à cette protection que
la France, madame la députée,
garde le taux d'inflation le plus
faible de la zone euro.
C'est un chiffre, c'est un fait.
Nous continuerons à faire cela, en
ciblant la protection des plus
fragiles, en aidant les
entreprises qui font également
face à l'explosion de leurs
factures.
Nous n'avons jamais laissé tomber
personne pendant une crise, ni
pendant le Covid, ni pendant les
autres crises.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Florence Goulet: Vous savez bien
que les Français sont obligés de
faire des choix et des sacrifices
sur le panier d'alimentation.
Par ailleurs, vos mesures ne sont
pas pérennes.
Vous savez que la crise est
appelée à durer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Jean-Marc
Tellier.
- Jean-Marc Tellier: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les ministres, chers collègues.
Les faits sont implacables.
En France, la pauvreté gagne du
terrain.
Plus de 10 millions de Français
vivent aujourd'hui sous le seuil
de pauvreté.
Les Restos du Coeur constatent une
hausse de 12% de l'aide
alimentaire.
Le rapport du Secours Catholique
et celui du Secours populaire
doivent nous alerter.
Notre jeunesse est impactée.
Les 18-25 ans représentent 24% des
travailleurs pauvres.
Quant aux privés d'emploi, moins
de 1 sur 2 est indemnisé.
Les fautifs, ce ne sont pas la
pandémie ou l'inflation.
Les fautifs, c'est vous.
Vous êtes responsables de la
déstructuration du code du
travail, de l'assurance-chômage,
véritable trappe à emplois
précaires.
Les élus locaux nous alertent sur
cette situation sociale
dramatique, qui met en première
ligne le service public et nos
centres communaux d'action
sociale.
L'explosion des dépenses liées à
l'énergie impacte les budgets des
collectivités.
Non maires sont très inquiets.
Quels services devront-ils
supprimer demain?
Chez moi, dans le Pas-de-Calais,
comme dans d'autres communes, nous
sommes laissés pour compte.
Comment expliquer que dans ma
région des Hauts-de-France, l'un
des territoires les plus pauvres
de France, seulement 8 communes
ont reçu votre aide?
Aucune dans le Pas-de-Calais, dans
la Somme...
Pouvez-vous nous assurer qu'aucune
commune ne passera au-dessus du
filet de sécurité?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci et la
parole est à monsieur Christophe
Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés, monsieur le député,
vous évoquez les remontées à
l'issue du vote du filet de
sécurité de 430 millions d'euros,
qui a fait l'objet
d'allers-retours entre la
représentation nationale ici, à
l'Assemblée, au Sénat, et le
gouvernement, pour être retenu
dans le cadre du PLFS définitif.
Dans ce filet, il y a une somme,
avec un accord politique entre la
majorité et l'opposition.
Il y avait eu une estimation à
22.000 communes, évoqué dans
l'hémicycle.
Aujourd'hui, on a le sentiment que
ce seuil est trop haut pour
déclencher le financement des
sommes dont nous parlons.
A la minute où je vous parle, la
direction générale des
collectivités locales, les
allers-retours entre le ministère
de la Cohésion des territoires et
les remontées que nous avons sont
en train de reprendre ces
éléments.
L'engagement du gouvernement,
c'était bien cet accompagnement de
430 millions d'euros.
Si l'assouplissement des critères
est le moyen de tenir le niveau de
financement sur lequel nous nous
sommes mis d'accord, c'est une
perspective à laquelle nous
souscrivons.
Dans le même principe,
l'amendement qui a été déposé et
repris dans le cadre de la
première partie du budget sur le
soutien aux collectivités locales,
fait lui aussi l'objet d'un examen
pour qu'on vérifie si ce premier
critère sur la perspective
d'autofinancement, n'a pas été
trop restrictif sur la capacité à
pouvoir aider les collectivités.
L'engagement du gouvernement est
d'accompagner les collectivités
face à la flambée des prix.
C'est d'ajuster le filet à la
réalité de la somme sur laquelle
nous nous sommes mis d'accord.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Anne
Bergantz.
- Anne Bergantz: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les ministres, chers collègues, ma
question s'adresse à madame
Charlotte Caubel, secrétaire
d'Etat auprès de la ministre
chargée de l'Enfance.
Les institutions sont mises à
l'honneur.
Les événements organisés sont la
preuve de la volonté du
gouvernement d'obtenir les
avancées sur la protection de
l'enfance.
Le 13 septembre dernier, il y en
avait un autre.
Cependant, si des progrès
significatifs ont été réalisés ces
dernières années, beaucoup reste à
faire.
Un rapport de l'Unicef a paru
dimanche dernier, à l'occasion de
la Journée internationale des
droits de l'enfant, et fait état
d'une situation alarmante.
1 enfant meurt tous les cinq
jours, suite à des violences
majoritairement intrafamiliales.
Nous ne pouvons accepter une
France où une partie de nos
enfants ne sont pas protégés.
Il faut que tous les moyens soient
engagés pour faire cesser ces
situations.
Vous avez su identifier ces
difficultés en créant un comité
interministériel de l'enfance.
Pourriez-vous faire un retour des
échanges, suite à la réunion de ce
comité qui a lieu hier, et nous
préciser quelles mesures vous
envisagez pour lutter contre les
violences faites aux enfants?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame la
secrétaire d'Etat chargée de
l'Enfance.
- Charlotte Caubel: Madame la
députée, mesdames et messieurs les
députés.
Violences, charge mentale, de
nombreux signaux sont encore
alarmants.
Le Parlement et le gouvernement
sont pleinement mobilisés pour
l'enfance.
C'est dans cet objectif que la
Première ministre a réuni hier le
premier comité interministériel de
l'enfance, au lendemain de la
Journée internationale des droits
de l'enfant.
Avec l'ensemble des ministres
concernés, la Première ministre a
déterminé cinq chantiers
prioritaires et une quarantaine de
mesures, dont il m'appartiendra
d'assurer le suivi et la
coordination.
Le premier chantier, c'est celui
de la lutte des violences faites
aux enfants.
Les chiffres sont extrêmement
impressionnants.
Le ministre de l'Intérieur a
annoncé la création d'un office de
police judiciaire dédié aux
violences faites aux enfants.
Le garde des Sceaux portera une
circulaire de politique pénale
dédiée à ce sujet, qui sera
diffusée auprès des parquets.
Le second chantier, c'est celui de
la santé, la santé physique et
mentale de nos enfants.
Le ministre François Braun a
annoncé des assises de la santé
des enfants, au printemps
prochain.
Troisième priorité: le numérique.
Partout où sont nos enfants, nous
devons les protéger, notamment sur
Internet.
Un laboratoire a été lancé pour la
protection des enfants dans le
domaine du numérique.
Nous menons une campagne de
sensibilisation auprès des
parents.
Nous mènerons à terme la loi sur
le contrôle parental dans les
semaines qui viennent.
Notre action continuera à être
effective.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Estelle
Youssouffa.
- Estelle Youssouffa: Merci.
Cette question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre.
Nos compatriotes découvrent depuis
quelques jours la violence qui est
notre quotidien à Mayotte depuis
plus années.
En ce moment, les forces de
l'ordre affrontent les émeutiers.
A Mayotte, chaque jour, nos
enfants vont à l'école la peur au
ventre, parce que les
établissements scolaires sont
attaqués.
Les entreprises sont incendiées.
Les automobilistes sont agressés
par des hordes de jeunes déments
qui se déplacent par centaines.
Il y a des enfants de 12 à 13 ans,
armés de machettes, qui tuent, qui
sèment le chaos.
La plupart, ce sont des étrangers
en situation régulière qui sèment
la terreur pour nous faire fuir.
Depuis plusieurs mois, on attaque
les collèges et les lycées.
Maintenant, on attaque à la
machette.
Des morceaux de corps humains ont
été déposés en évidence sur la
route en début d'année pour
terroriser la population.
Deux personnes ont été torturées
et amputées à la machette, en
quelques jours.
Quel acte de barbarie
supplémentaire faut-il pour que la
République réagisse?
Quel traumatisme de plus
devons-nous subir pour que la
nation exprime sa solidarité avec
Mayotte?
Quel avenir pour Mayotte, si nos
enfants sont assassinés quand ils
vont à l'école?
La population veut se rendre
justice elle-même.
C'est de la légitime défense quand
elle est attaquée et abandonnée à
elle-même.
Le ministère de l'Intérieur a
envoyé des renforts.
Merci.
Mais quand allez-vous ordonner le
déploiement de la marine nationale
pour protéger notre frontière et
donner des moyens à la justice?
Qu'allez-vous faire pour éviter la
guerre civile?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Gérald
Darmanin.
- Gérald Darmanin: Merci.
Madame la députée Estelle
Youssouffa, nous connaissons votre
engagement pour l'île de Mayotte.
Vous répétez sans cesse que les
habitants de Mayotte, qui ont
choisi de rester dans la
République, ont besoin de la
protection de l'Etat.
L'augmentation des moyens
continue.
Nous avons envoyé des équipes pour
rétablir la paix publique.
Il y a des actes inacceptables qui
ont été commis.
Le président de la République
lui-même s'engage à trouver des
moyens pour aider Mayotte.
En 2021, 29.000 interpellations de
personnes étrangères en situation
irrégulière.
Sur le plan judiciaire: 324
passeurs ont été interpellés.
Il faut les présenter à la
justice.
Le garde des Sceaux réfléchit à
des moyens.
Sur le côté militaire, nous avons
entendu votre demande.
Nous travaillons en partie ce soir
à l'élaboration d'une loi
militaire pour aider la Guyane et
Mayotte, afin de renforcer leurs
moyens militaires.
L'Etat travaille sur une opération
pour mettre fin aux problèmes sur
ce territoire.
L'Etat va mettre en place des
moyens pour inverser le cours de
la violence.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Jocelyn
Dessigny.
- Jocelyn Dessigny: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de l'Education, monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
Les investigations de la cellule
antiterroriste révèlent que Samuel
Paty se sentait traqué, se
trouvait dans un état de grande
anxiété.
Les recherches qu'il faisait sur
Google le montrent.
Menaces à l'ordre public, code
pénal.
Le jour de son assassinat, il
demande à un de ses collègues de
le raccompagner chez lui.
Dans son sac à dos, on a retrouvé
un marteau.
Tous ces signes prouvent
l'effroyable solitude qu'il
ressentait, face à une menace
sérieuse et potentiellement
mortelle.
Cela pose question, alors même que
le personnel d'accueil du collège
ne s'émeut ni des appels d'alerte
qu'il a reçus du Maroc, des
Etats-Unis, du Canada et du monde
entier.
Malgré l'ampleur de la politique
et son caractère alarmant, c'est
Samuel Paty qui doit se justifier
face à ses collègues, en
revendiquant son athéisme.
Dans cette histoire tragique, le
grand absent, c'est l'Etat.
Comment un enseignant peut se
trouver menacé de mort, en danger
dans son établissement, sans que
l'Etat lui fournisse l'attention
et la protection dont il a besoin?
Tous les signalements remontent.
Que pouvez-vous nous dire de plus
sur le nombre de signalements
reçus et sur les mesures prises en
conséquence?
Quelles sont les mesures de
protection mises en place?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye, ministre de l'Education
nationale.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les députés,
monsieur le député, la
commémoration de l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty, le 16 octobre
dernier, a été l'occasion de
réaffirmer les valeurs de la
République qui sont des valeurs de
la laïcité.
La laïcité, ce n'est pas seulement
une contrainte, c'est la garantie
de l'émancipation par le savoir,
la transmission de savoirs dans
les établissements scolaires.
A cette occasion, et dans la
foulée des vacances d'automne,
j'ai eu l'occasion de préciser un
certain nombre de mesures sur la
protection des enseignants.
D'abord, la protection
fonctionnelle, qui est accordée
par l'administration aux
enseignants qui le demandent.
Par ailleurs, le dépôt
systématique de plaintes en lien
avec les préfectures.
Les dépôts sont faits par les
enseignants quand ils sont
menacés, mais aussi par les chefs
d'établissement.
Nous le faisons systématiquement,
avec l'appui de l'administration
centrale.
Enfin, nous enjoignons également
les personnels de l'Education
nationale à faire remonter toute
menace ou toute tentative
d'intimidation sur les réseaux
sociaux, ou dans les enceintes
scolaires, afin de mesurer
précisément ces phénomènes et à
pouvoir agir.
Nous protégeons, nous surveillons
les phénomènes que vous indiquez,
de manière à ce que les menaces
qui puissent porter sur les
enseignants ne se reproduisent
pas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Jocelyn Dessigny: Dans ma
circonscription comme dans
l'ensemble du territoire, de
nombreux enseignants
s'autocensurent face à une menace
islamique croissante.
Quand allez-vous protéger les
professeurs pour qu'ils puissent
enseigner sereinement les valeurs
de la République?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Thomas Cazenave.
- Thomas Cazenave: 5 milliards en
cinq ans, c'est le budget qui a
été alloué au programme Action
coeur de ville lors de la dernière
mandature et qui a bénéficié à 234
villes de taille moyenne sur tout
le territoire.
Ce programme répondait à un
objectif clair: réhabiliter les
centres-villes pour soutenir
l'activité économique et
culturelle de ces territoires.
Action coeur de ville a été
largement plébiscité par les élus
locaux de tous bords, qui se sont
pleinement engagés à porter des
projets ambitieux au service de
leur ville.
Grâce au volontarisme de l'Etat,
des collectivités territoriales,
de la Banque des territoires,
d'Action logement, de l'Agence
nationale pour l'habitat, 6500
actions ont été engagées dans tous
les domaines.
79.000 logements ont été rénovés,
1000 cellules commerciales ont été
restructurées et requalifiées.
De nombreuses opérations de
réhabilitation du patrimoine ont
été engagées.
Aujourd'hui, les premiers
résultats sont là.
Cela confirme le bien-fondé du
programme et de cette méthode
originale.
La progression de la vacance
commerciale a été stoppée et
commence à refluer.
Les transactions immobilières sont
redevenues dynamiques.
La fréquentation des
centres-villes est repartie à la
hausse.
Les élus de ces villes ont exprimé
leurs attentes très fortes pour
pouvoir continuer ce chantier qui,
pour tenir toutes ses promesses,
doit s'inscrire dans la durée.
Vous avez annoncé dimanche un
nouveau programme doté de 5
milliards d'euros pour poursuivre
Action coeur de ville.
Pouvez-vous nous dire comment et
dans quel délai ce nouveau
programme sera mis en oeuvre?
- Caroline Cayeux: Merci.
Monsieur le député Thomas
Cazenave, alors que s'ouvre cette
semaine le congrès des maires,
merci d'attirer l'attention sur ce
programme Action coeur de ville
qui a été un formidable
accélérateur pour les projets des
234 villes partenaires.
C'est un parfait exemple de la
nouvelle méthode poursuivie par le
gouvernement dès le premier
quinquennat, et que nous allons
poursuivre, comme vous l'avez
souligné.
Depuis son lancement, les villes
moyennes ont bénéficié grâce à
l'Etat et à nos partenaires, la
Banque des territoires, Action
logement, de formidables outils
pour revitaliser leurs
centres-villes.
Les résultats que vous mentionnez
montrent que la promesse politique
a été tenue.
Sur la deuxième phase du programme
que j'ai annoncée il y a quelques
jours, j'ai précisé les grands
axes qui devraient bénéficier
d'abord d'au moins 5 milliards sur
les quatre années qui viennent.
Ce programme, à la différence du
premier, qui visait à la
revitalisation des centres-villes,
nous avons fait le choix de faire
de la transition écologique et de
la transition énergétique le
véritable conducteur d'Action
coeur de ville 2.
C'est un objectif crucial, au
moment où nos communes traversent
un défi structurel représenté par
l'urgence climatique.
Ce sera par exemple
l'intensification de la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments publics,
des écoles, des logements
résidentiels.
Des mesures fortes aussi pour le
traitement des friches, qui va
continuer pour ces villes où la
requalification des entrées de
ville pour favoriser la nature en
ville.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Bastien Lachaud.
- Bastien Lachaud: Monsieur le
ministre, une jeune femme
d'Aubervilliers
habitant en cité a froid.
Son appartement n'a pas été
chauffé de tout l'hiver.
L'hiver est à nouveau là, elle a à
nouveau froid.
Près de 20% des logements HLM de
la ville d'Aubervilliers ne sont
pas chauffés.
Entre 2018 et 2022, vous avez
privé les organismes HLM de 6
milliards d'euros.
Le résultat est accablant.
Chute des nouvelles constructions,
immeubles mal entretenus,
ascenseurs et chaudières qui ne
marchent pas...
Vous avez clochardisé le logement
social.
Aujourd'hui, en pleine crise de
l'énergie, vous abandonnez les
bailleurs sociaux.
La moitié d'entre eux vont devoir
renégocier leur contrat d'énergie
en 2023, avec des tarifs parfois
multipliés par 3 ou 4.
Et votre bouclier tarifaire est
une passoire, qui ne découvre pas
à 100%.
L'Union sociale de l'habitat, qui
regroupe les bailleurs sociaux, ne
cesse de tirer la sonnette
d'alarme.
Les hausses des tarifs se
répercutent sur les locataires.
Le thermomètre descend, mais les
prix, eux, augmentent.
Ceux des loyers, jusqu'à 3% en
janvier, ceux des charges qui vont
exploser du fait de la crise
énergétique.
Comment faire face quand on est à
quelques euros près chaque mois
et que dans le logement social,
35% des habitants vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté?
La majorité gagne seulement le
SMIC.
Vont-ils devoir choisir entre se
loger, se chauffer et manger?
Alors, qu'attendez-vous pour taxer
les superprofits, pour bloquer les
prix de l'énergie, pour protéger
et aider réellement les bailleurs
sociaux, pour que nos concitoyens
les plus modestes n'aient pas à
grelotter de froid chez eux cet
hiver?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivier Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Monsieur le
député Lachaud, si vous connaissez
un organisme de logement social en
Seine-Saint-Denis qui n'est pas
capable de chauffer ses
locataires, je m'étonne que vous
ne m'en parliez que seulement.
On aurait pu en parler très
largement, mon adresse est
ouverte, et je peux vous assurer
qu'aucun bailleur social en
Seine-Saint-Denis ne chauffe pas
ses locataires.
Pour ce qui est du bouclier, vous
le savez, le gouvernement a agi
pour des boucliers individuels et
du bouclier collectif.
Les boucliers collectifs au gaz
s'appliquent depuis avril 2022 et
ont été prolongés jusqu'à la fin
de cette année, et seront
prolongés encore en 2023.
Ils sont équivalents à ceux des
boucliers individuels et ils
marchent aussi pour les réseaux de
chauffage urbain.
Oui, il y avait un souci sur le
chauffage collectif électrique.
Ce souci, nous sommes en train de
le régler.
La Première ministre l'a annoncé.
Nous ferons paraître très
rapidement les décrets permettant
à toutes les copropriétés ainsi
qu'aux parties communes d'être
soumises au même bouclier.
Nous y travaillons tous les jours
avec l'Union sociale de l'habitat,
avec les syndics, pour aider
l'ensemble de ces difficultés.
Il reste encore un certain nombre
de difficultés à régler, mais je
peux vous assurer que nous y
travaillons d'arrache-pied.
- Bastien Lachaud: Vous me dites
que je ne vous en parle que
maintenant, mais vous n'avez pas
encore publié les décrets.
Donc, vous n'avez rien planifié.
Aujourd'hui, les gens ont froid et
c'est votre politique qui en est
la cause.
- Olivier Klein: Je ne vous parle
pas des boucliers, je vous parle
du logement social à
Aubervilliers, dans lequel il y
aurait, d'après vous, du chauffage
en panne.
Je vous donne rendez-vous dans ce
logement social et nous irons
ensemble.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet:
La parole est à
Agnès Carel.
- Agnès Carel: Monsieur le
ministre, la forte augmentation
des coûts de l'énergie pèse sur le
budget des ménages, des
collectivités mais également des
entreprises.
Ce gouvernement et cette majorité
ont mis en place un bouclier
tarifaire qui protège les ménages
plus que partout ailleurs en
Europe.
Un filet de sécurité à destination
des collectivités qui sera
renforcé et recentré, l'année
prochaine, à l'initiative du
groupe Horizons.
Pour les entreprises, vous avez
annoncé la mise en place d'aides
ciblées en fonction de leur taille
et des besoins.
Partout dans nos territoires, les
chefs d'entreprise s'inquiètent
alors qu'ils doivent signer leurs
contrats d'approvisionnement pour
l'année prochaine.
Bien souvent, les prix sont
multipliés par 3, 4 ou 5.
Ce sont des filières entières qui
sont en danger et des centaines de
milliers d'entreprises qui
craignent de devoir freiner, voire
stopper leur activité, ou même de
mettre la clé sous la porte.
Dans ma circonscription, la
filière de la pomme de terre est
fortement impactée par cette
situation, comme le sont dans
chacun de nos territoires nos
agriculteurs, artisans et chefs
d'entreprise et industrie.
Face à ces situations critiques,
le groupe Horizons aura loi
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables un amendement afin
de permettre aux collectivités et
aux entreprises de résilier à tout
moment leur contrat d'électricité
ou de gaz afin de bénéficier des
tarifs de marchés plus favorables
en fonction de la conjoncture.
Pouvez-vous nous dire très
concrètement et avec pragmatisme
ce qu'ils doivent faire?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Bruno Le Maire.
- Bruno Le Maire: Merci.
Madame la députée Carel, je
profite de votre question pour
inviter tous les chefs
d'entreprise,
dirigeants d'une PME ou d'une très
grande entreprise, à déposer leur
facture énergétique sur le site
des impôts.
Toutes celles qui ont une
difficulté pour payer une facture
d'électricité ou de gaz en 2022
auront droit, si leur facture a
beaucoup augmenté, à des aides qui
pourront aller jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2023, jusqu'à 4 millions
d'euros pour les PME, jusqu'à 150
millions d'euros pour les grandes
entreprises industrielles.
Je veux lever un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes.
J'entends ces inquiétudes.
J'étais, hier, avec la ministre en
charge des PME, Olivia Grégoire, à
Montceau-les-Mines, à la rencontre
des boulangers, pour les assurer
de notre soutien.
Toutes les entreprises sont
concernées, pas uniquement les
PME.
Nous veillerons à l'application de
la charte signée par les
énergéticiens.
Toutes les entreprises ont droit à
plusieurs offres.
Elles doivent pouvoir comparer et
prendre le meilleur prix.
Nous veillerons à l'équité de
concurrence entre l'Allemagne et
la France.
Les entreprises françaises seront
aussi bien protégées que les
entreprises allemandes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Madame Carel?
- Agnès Carel: Merci.
Cela correspond à une réelle
préoccupation de nos entreprises
et à une très forte attente d'une
communication saine et clair.
Je vous remercie beaucoup.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Elie Califer.
- Elie Califer: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la Transition
énergétique.
La géothermie est une énergie
d'avenir.
La Banque Européenne
d'Investissement et la Banque
centrale allemande ont eu
conscience de cela, en finançant
la centrale géothermique du Kenya,
pour plus de 270 millions d'euros.
Dans sa politique de transition
énergétique, présentée la semaine
dernière, la France semble ignorer
une de ses richesses présentes
dans les régions ultra
périphériques.
La géothermie est utilisée en
Guadeloupe.
Au moment où nous parlons de
transition énergétique, il est
temps de saisir avec détermination
cette source d'énergie décarbonée
pour renforcer notre mix
énergétique guadeloupéen français.
Nous le savons, la géothermie est
vertueuse, inépuisable.
Pas de carbone.
Elle permettra en plus de
fabriquer de l'hydrogène sans
émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
On pourra sortir du photovoltaïque
chinois, ainsi.
Pouvez-vous ramener EDF, qui vient
de bénéficier de subventions
d'Etat, dans le capital de la
société de géothermie?
Où en sommes-nous avec le centre
d'excellence sur la géothermie que
devait implanter l'Etat en
Guadeloupe?
Quels sont vos engagements forts
pour le développement de la
géothermie en France et dans les
outre-mer?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Jean-François Carenco.
- Jean-François Carenco: Monsieur
le député Califer, la géothermie
est en effet une énergie
renouvelable prometteuse qui
permet de produire l'électricité,
la chaleur et le froid de manière
décarbonée.
Il y a une véritable opportunité.
Nous soutenons le développement de
la géothermie, qui peut devenir
non seulement pour la Guadeloupe
mais pour tous les territoires
d'outre-mer, et je pense notamment
à la Martinique, un atout dans
leur trajectoire de décarbonation
et d'indépendance énergétique.
Le ministère de la Transition
énergétique va annoncer très
prochainement un plan d'action
géothermie.
Sur la géothermie profonde qui
concerne tout particulièrement la
Guadeloupe, ce plan vise à
améliorer la connaissance du
sous-sol pour limiter les risques
associés au projet de géothermie
profonde.
Il s'agit aussi de faire monter
pour les acteurs locaux,
d'accompagner les porteurs de
projets dans leur déploiement de
solutions.
Nous avons dès ce soir une réunion
interministérielle où sera abordé
spécifiquement le cas de la
société dont vous parlez.
Vous pouvez compter sur moi pour
défendre le développement de la
géothermie et de renouvelables
dans nos outre-mer.
Je connais tous les projets en
Guadeloupe.
C'est dans cette perspective et
dans le cadre de la PPE à modifier
de manière simplifiée qu'ils
seront étudiés.
J'ai par ailleurs reçu récemment
les deux promoteurs potentiels sur
les deux projets nouveaux
existants, et les contacts sont
déjà établis avec EDF pour sortir
un prix raisonnable.
Vous pouvez compter sur moi.
- Elie Califer: Nous comptons sur
vous, mais nous comptons surtout
sur l'engagement ferme et concret
de l'Etat en faveur de la
géothermie, avec des réponses et
des engagements précis.
Ca fait 40 ans qu'on a commencé.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Steve Chailloux.
- Steve Chailloux: Mon
intervention d'aujourd'hui face à
la représentation nationale
sortira quelque peu de
l'orthodoxie habituelle de cet
exercice bien connu des députés
que nous sommes, et je vous prie
par avance de m'excuser.
Elle s'inscrit en effet dans les
tiraillements du coeur et de la
main qui nous imposent le deuil
produit par l'innommable tragédie
dont souffre actuellement
l'ensemble de mon peuple
polynésien de souche, de coeur ou
d'adoption.
Le dimanche 6 novembre dernier, à
la suite des violentes pluies qui
se sont abattues en Polynésie, le
coeur battant de notre archipel, a
été la victime d'une catastrophe.
Face au déchaînement de la nature,
nous devons rester humbles, car ce
jour-là, plusieurs victimes ont
été englouties, notamment des
enfants.
Une femme enceinte de huit mois a
également été des victimes.
L'inextricable douleur suscitée
par cette tragédie a conduit
jusqu'à hier encore à la
mobilisation massive d'un nombre
sans précédent de bénévoles venus
aider des secours dans la
recherche de nos enfants,
malheureusement en vain,
puisqu'ils n'ont jamais été
retrouvés.
Je voudrais avec émotion saluer le
dévouement remarquable dont ont
fait preuve les gendarmes, les
pompiers, les plongeurs, les
bénévoles.
Je salue également
les élus, sans oublier le soutien
du haut-commissaire de la
République ainsi que les services
du gouvernement de la Polynésie.
Je souhaite
exprimer cette émotion au sein de
cet hémicycle.
Il n'y a point de plus grand
hommage que celui qui peut être
donné par le coeur même de notre
démocratie.
Liberté, égalité, fraternité,
telle est la devise de notre
république.
Je suis fier que les Polynésiens
aient fait preuve pendant 10 jours
d'une admirable fraternité.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
Monsieur le ministre?
Quand on est ému...
- Monsieur le député,
effectivement, le 6 novembre, à
6h30, la Polynésie a été traversée
par un épisode de pluies très
violent qui a entraîné la crue
d'un cours d'eau situé dans une
vallée difficilement accessible.
Un véhicule avec ses occupants,
deux femme, dont une enceinte, un
homme et trois enfants qui étaient
en train de traverser ce cours
d'eau ont été emportés par les
flots.
Aussitôt, des moyens
considérables, humains et
matériels, de l'Etat et de
l'ensemble des collectivités ont
été déployés en coordination avec
la commune concernée.
La police municipale, les
sapeurs-pompiers, les communes
voisines, la gendarmerie, et les
bénévoles venus de toute la
Polynésie ont été mobilisés.
En fin d'après-midi, une femme
blessée a pu être hélitreuillée
vers 19h.
Elle est aujourd'hui hors de
danger.
Un homme a été retrouvé décédé aux
alentours de 22h.
Depuis, les recherches se sont
poursuivies avec des moyens locaux
appuyés par les moyens de l'Etat,
sous coordination.
Le Haut Commissariat et tous les
services de l'Etat sont restés en
appui de la commune.
Mais après 15 jours de recherches,
les autorités locales ont pris
décision de les arrêter sans avoir
retrouvé le corps des quatre
victimes restantes, une femme
enceinte et trois enfants.
C'est toute la population
polynésienne qui vit cette
tragédie.
Je veux comme vous ici saluer le
courage et l'aide de tous les
acteurs qui se sont mobilisés pour
essayer de retrouver ces
malheureux.
La solidarité face à la détresse a
été exemplaire.
Il faut nous en féliciter.
Toutes les composantes de la
république ont démontré leur
capacité à travailler ensemble.
Mais il nous faut aussi maintenant
travailler sur les questions du
changement climatique outre-mer.
Nous avons commencé à travailler
pour établir un bilan global.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Frédéric Zgainski.
- Frédéric Zgainski: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre chargée des PME, du
commerce de l'artisanat et du
tourisme.
A l'heure de la sobriété
énergétique, nous devons faire de
la lutte contre tous les types de
gaspillage une priorité.
Je me réjouis que votre ministère
ait ainsi pris à bras-le-corps le
sujet très important du gaspillage
alimentaire.
Le décret paru au Journal officiel
ce 18 novembre relatif aux
modalités de l'information des
consommateurs sur le caractère
consommable des denrées
alimentaires en témoigne.
En effet, le sujet concerne près
de 10 millions de tonnes de
nourriture consommable jetées
chaque année en France.
Les nombreuses initiatives visent
depuis des années à mettre fin à
ce gaspillage, qui reste
inacceptable, car une grande
partie de ces aliments reste
consommable après l'expiration de
la date de durabilité minimale.
Il convient donc d'informer les
consommateurs sur la signification
de cette inscription et de
rassurer sur les enjeux de santé
qu'ils peuvent soulever, qui sont
bien légitimes.
La loi votée par notre assemblée,
en 2020, et soutenue par les
députés du groupe démocrate,
prévoyait des dispositions qui
allaient en ce sens et que votre
décret vient concrétiser.
C'est normalement le cas de la
mention supplémentaire qui pourra
désormais accompagner la DDM.
Nous avons de ce point de vue un
important travail de pédagogie à
faire auprès des consommateurs,
notamment pour lever les craintes
en matière de risques pour la
santé.
Madame la ministre, pouvez-vous
nous dire ce que, concrètement, ce
décret va changer et quels efforts
compte déployer le gouvernement
auprès des industriels d'un côté
et des consommateurs de l'autre
pour que cette mesure puisse
contribuer réellement à changer
nos pratiques?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci.
Monsieur le député Frédéric
Zgainski, le gouvernement ne
relâche pas ses efforts pour
protéger le pouvoir d'achat et
améliorer aussi l'information
faite aux consommateurs dans cette
période d'inflation.
La mesure que vous évoquez est
très importante, puisqu'elle est
très concrète.
Elle va venir ajouter une
information supplémentaire, et on
va fortement encourager l'ensemble
des distributeurs et des
industriels à la mettre en place,
pour lutter contre le gaspillage
alimentaire, qui est un désastre
écologique mais qui est aussi un
désastre économique.
Imaginez-vous qu'aujourd'hui, un
Français jette en moyenne,
mesdames messieurs les
parlementaires, pas moins de 30 kg
de nourriture par an.
Cela représente 460 euros qui sont
directement jetés par an.
Sur ces 30 kg,
il y a des déchets alimentaires
non consommés encore emballés.
Il n'y avait que la date limite de
consommation qui informait les
consommateurs sur les produits
frais de la date au-delà de
laquelle il ne fallait pas
consommer ces produits frais, au
risque d'avoir un souci de santé.
En réalité, il n'y avait pas
d'information sur les produits
secs, sur les conserves, sur les
pâtes alimentaires, et nous avons
donc décidé, Bruno Le Maire a
signé le décret la semaine
dernière, d'ajouter la date de
durabilité maximale.
En un mot, vous trouverez
désormais sur les produits secs
une information plus explicite qui
expliquera que ce produit peut
être consommé après cette date.
Donc, il y aura moins de
gaspillage et une possibilité de
consommer sans aucun risque pour
la santé pour les consommateurs.
La date limite de consommation est
consacrée aux produits frais, et
la date de durabilité maximale
sera consacrée aux produits secs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Emmanuel Maquet.
- Emmanuel Maquet: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre du Travail, du Plein
emploi et de l'Insertion.
Plus vos intentions sur la réforme
des retraites se précisent, plus
elles révèlent des renoncements
majeurs.
Le dernier en date concerne les
régimes spéciaux.
Alors que les Français demandent
la fin des privilèges aujourd'hui
injustifiés de certains d'entre
eux, vous proposez leur
suppression.
La situation financière des
retraites est urgente, mais vous
nous proposez de légiférer pendant
40 ans, c'est plutôt la clause du
petit-fils, voire de
l'arrière-petit-fils.
Vous vous félicitez que le climat
des négociations avec les
syndicats soit bon.
Mais quand on connaît le
conservatisme de certains d'entre
eux, ce n'est pas un bon signe
pour votre réforme.
A l'heure où le gouvernement nous
parle de l'acceptabilité, il
serait bon que l'acceptabilité de
cette réforme soit celle des
Français.
L'acceptabilité, c'est que chacun
fasse un effort, oui, un effort,
et pas uniquement le secteur
privé.
Au contraire, votre réforme qui
prétend unifier les régimes oppose
les fonctionnaires, les salariés
du privé et laisse de côté les
régimes spéciaux.
La situation des finances sociales
et la sauvegarde de notre modèle
pour les Français exige du courage
et de l'équité.
Le courage serait d'assurer une
hausse de l'âge de départ pour
tous, comme le groupe Les
Républicains le demande depuis des
années, comme tous nos voisins
européens l'ont fait.
Travailler plus longtemps alors
que notre espérance de vie nous le
permet, c'est préserver le système
de retraite mais aussi dégager les
moyens de relever le minimum
retraite au-delà de 1100 euros,
comme vous le prétendez.
Vous avez abandonné l'idée d'un
système universel, et avec lui
l'idée d'un système équitable.
Ma question est donc simple:
combien de dettes
supplémentaires...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Monsieur le
député, je vais essayer de
répondre simplement.
Je ferai aussi une remarque sur le
contexte politique dans lequel
nous allons examiner cette réforme
des retraites.
Le président de la République,
lorsqu'il était en campagne pour
la présidentielle du printemps
dernier, a pris un certain nombre
d'engagements.
Parmi ses engagements, il y a
l'amélioration du système de
retraite et son retour à
l'équilibre.
Il a fixé le cap de relever
progressivement l'âge de départ de
62 à 67 ans, en 2027.
C'est ce cap que nous tenons.
C'est sur le mandat de l'élection
présidentielle que j'ai ouvert,
sous l'autorité de la Première
ministre, un dernier cycle de
concertations avec les
organisations syndicales et
patronales.
Nous avons un premier objectif qui
est d'améliorer le système de
retraite qui se caractérise par
des petites pensions qui sont
beaucoup trop basses.
Ceci ne tient pas assez compte de
l'usure professionnelle ni de la
pénibilité, ni de la précarité des
carrières et de leur caractère
parfois haché.
Améliorer, c'est faire plus
d'équité.
L'équité, c'est justement de mener
la réforme des régimes spéciaux,
avec le choix de la clause du
grand-père.
Les contrats sont assortis de
droits et de devoirs que nous
tenons de part et d'autre.
Ca ne signifie pas que la réforme
ne s'applique pas.
L'intégralité des Français,
régimes publics, régimes privés,
régimes spéciaux, seront aussi
amenés à travailler plus longtemps
et à voir leur âge légal de départ
se décaler.
Vous nous implorez d'avoir le
courage que vous n'avez jamais eu.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Alexis
Izard.
- Alexis Izard: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres, mes chers collègues, ma
question s'adresse au ministre
délégué chargé de l'Industrie.
Hier débutait la 11e semaine de
l'industrie qui valorise les
acteurs du secteur en proposant
des événements pédagogiques et de
découverte du métier.
Cela permet de promouvoir la
mixité des métiers et de
promouvoir la place des femmes
dans les filières.
Depuis cinq ans, il y a plus
d'emplois, d'attractivité et
d'investissements.
Le secteur industriel a recommencé
à créer des emplois.
Ce n'était pas arrivé depuis 10
ans.
Ces résultats sont le résultat
d'une politique industrielle
conséquente avec des efforts de
structure et une baisse de la
fiscalité.
Ce mouvement doit se poursuivre.
Nous avons la volonté politique de
le faire et des moyens via France
2030.
Il faut donner l'accès à
l'industrie à toutes et à tous.
Cependant, l'industrie souffre de
contrevérités aujourd'hui.
Elle serait polluante, difficile,
à la chaîne.
La réalité est toute autre.
Vous avez pu le constater quand
vous êtes venu chez moi, en
Essonne, soutenir l'industrie,
monsieur le ministre.
Vous avez vu la variété de ses
profils et sa féminisation.
Nous devons rendre attractif ce
secteur et élargir le vivier de
recrutement.
Quelles actions allez-vous mettre
en oeuvre pour poursuivre ce
mouvement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Roland
Lescure.
- Roland Lescure: Merci.
Mon micro ne fonctionne pas.
J'espère que celui-ci est made in
France.
Monsieur le député Alexis Izard,
j'ai une grande mission: faire de
la France une économie verte et
souveraine, et cela passera par
l'industrie.
Nous avons un cap, c'est France
nation verte.
Nous avons des moyens, France
2030, qui, après avoir été lancé
par le président, avec déjà des
prêts de 10 milliards d'euros
d'engagements.
C'est avec un objectif clair:
accélérer ce que nous avons fait
depuis cinq ans.
La semaine de l'industrie doit
nous permettre de redonner envie
aux jeunes et aux moins jeunes de
rejoindre les métiers de
l'industrie.
J'engage les députés à se rendre
dans les industries, à rencontrer
les industriels, les jeunes hommes
et les jeunes filles qui
souhaitent rejoindre l'industrie.
J'étais hier avec la ministre de
l'Egalité femmes-hommes.
Nous avons rencontré des jeunes
filles de lycée qui souhaitent
rejoindre l'industrie.
Nous ouvrons Bercy à l'industrie.
J'aurai l'occasion de rejoindre le
ministre de l'Education nationale
pour présenter les métiers de
l'industrie.
Nous terminerons cette journée par
un concours d'éloquence.
Nous ferons le procès de
l'industrie, et j'espère que
l'industrie gagnera avec brio.
C'est l'avenir de la France et des
jeunes.
C'est l'avenir de la planète.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Frédéric
Cabrolier pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Frédéric Cabrolier: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de la Transition écologique et de
la transition et de la cohésion
des territoires.
La loi résilience a été votée sans
concertation avec les élus locaux.
Ils sont aujourd'hui très
inquiets.
Dorénavant, il faut respecter une
règle: jusqu'en 2030, seront
autorisées à la construction 50%
des superficies artificialisées.
Il y a dans ce calcul des grands
projets nationaux sur lesquels les
élus locaux n'ont aucune prise.
Or, le rythme d'artificialisation
se situe autour de 28.400 ha par
an.
Il y a des différences marquées
entre les intercommunalités.
Vous comprenez que c'est une
situation injuste.
Certains territoires ont été peu
artificialisés sur les 10
dernières années.
L'application stricte de cette loi
pourrait pénaliser le comportement
vertueux de certaines
collectivités.
Depuis la crise sanitaire, le
monde rural est plébiscité.
Il faut pouvoir accueillir dans
les meilleures conditions celles
et ceux qui souhaitent venir
s'installer en compagne.
Cette loi aura l'effet inverse.
Les campagnes vont continuer de se
dépeupler, au détriment des
grandes métropoles qui ne sont pas
des modèles de vertu en matière
environnementale.
Les efforts de certains
doivent-ils contribuer à ce que
les mauvais élèves du passé
consomment plus de terrain que
ceux qui ont été vertueux dans le
passé?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci.
J'espère vous apporter des
éléments de réponses qui vont vous
convenir.
Toutes les heures, nous
consommons, nous artificialisons
l'équivalent de cinq terrains de
football.
Je comprends que pour certains, ce
ne soit pas grave.
Mais si vous voulez qu'on préserve
notre agriculture, nos sols, qu'on
garde une capacité de captation du
carbone, lutter contre
l'artificialisation est une
nécessité.
La loi à laquelle vous faites
référence a été votée par
l'Assemblée et le Sénat, à l'issue
d'une commission mixte paritaire
et elle a réuni tout le monde sur
cet objectif.
Le sujet, ce sont ses modalités
d'application.
Les difficultés liées au décret de
la fin du mois d'avril m'ont
conduit à les suspendre et à les
réécrire.
Le point que vous soulignez est
juste.
Il ne faut pas que le zéro
artificialisation ce soit de
prendre ce qu'on a fait par le
passé et de le diviser par deux.
La loi prévoit des mesures par
région pour tenir compte des
différences de dynamiques de
chaque territoire.
A la minute où on se parle, avec
l'association des maires de
France, avec l'association des
régions de France, nous discutons
pour proposer des évolutions de ce
texte.
Nous voulons faire en sorte qu'on
n'applique pas une loi aveugle,
mais qu'on tienne un objectif de
lutte contre l'artificialisaton,
que nous ne pouvons pas différer.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à la madame
Frédérique Meunier.
- Frédérique Meunier: Merci.
Nos communes rurales s'inquiètent.
Elles expriment leur préoccupation
concernant les conséquences de la
crise économique et financière sur
leur dépense et leurs recettes,
sur leur capacité à investir et
sur le maintien d'une offre de
services de proximité adaptée aux
besoins de la population.
Elles doivent faire face à une
situation sans précédent.
L'augmentation de l'énergie, des
produits alimentaires et des
matériaux, qui connaissent une
hausse spectaculaire.
Cela compromet l'équilibre des
budgets de fonctionnement et les
capacités d'investissement.
Ces mesures de restrictions
financières de nos communes ne
justifient pas le reste.
Vous sanctionnez les communes
alors qu'elles ne le méritent pas.
Ce sont des restrictions imposées
à la population.
C'est autant de moins pour
financer l'offre de services.
L'association des maires de France
a fait des propositions pour
indexer la DGF en 2023.
Pour créer un bouclier énergétique
d'urgence, plafonnant le prix
d'achat de l'électricité pour
toutes les collectivités locales.
Au moment où se déroule, à Paris,
le congrès des maires, allez-vous
entendre la voix des élus locaux
et soutenir les positions de
l'association des maires?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Vous évoquez
deux sujets: les communes rurales
et toutes les communes.
Vendredi, nous allons réunir le
Parlement rural pour évoquer un
certain nombre de propositions
concrètes.
Je pense aux besoins
d'accompagnement spécifiques qui
existent pour ces territoires.
Nous avons prévu une demi-journée
d'échanges spécifiques sur ces
territoires dont nous savons
l'attractivité, les inquiétudes.
Il y a une suggestion, qui serait
le transfert de la DGF des
communes vers l'intercommunalité.
Nous ne souhaitons pas cela.
Je profite de ce moment pour le
dire de manière claire.
Vous évoquez la situation plus
largement, et la nature du soutien
que nous apportons est assez
commune.
On nous demande de faire
davantage, mais c'est 320 millions
contre 0 ces dernières années et
près de 12 milliards de pertes
pendant
le quinquennat de François
Hollande.
Il y a 1,5 milliard d'euros sur
lesquels la construction
législative se poursuit.
- Frédérique Meunier: Je vous
rappelle que les communes sont les
socles de notre démocratie.
Ne commettez pas l'erreur du
passé.
Vous avez parlé du passé.
Vous nous remettez souvent le
passé en pleine figure.
Il y a la loi
NOTRe de 2014 qui a été un échec.
Vous parlez du Parlement rural,
c'est une nouveauté?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Christine
Arrighi.
- Christine Arrighi: Merci.
Ma question s'adressait à madame
Elisabeth Borne, mais elle n'est
pas là.
La ristourne gouvernementale sur
le carburant coûtera plus de 8
milliards d'euros aux finances
publiques.
Nous avons déjà proposé l'adoption
d'une mesure plus efficace et peu
coûteuse.
C'est le passage à 110 km/h sur
l'autoroute.
Rouler à 110 km/h au lieu de 130
permet de réduire de 20% le
carburant consommé.
C'est une mesure de sobriété, de
préservation du pouvoir d'achat,
une mesure pour réduire notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles.
C'est primordial de préserver les
vies humaines.
Aujourd'hui, 63% des Français y
sont favorables.
Madame Borne a exprimé la semaine
dernière son désaccord car "on ne
peut pas fonctionner à coups
d'interdiction".
Je propose d'inscrire une telle
mesure dans une perspective plus
large, d'acceptation sociale, en
faveur de l'écologie et du pouvoir
d'achat.
Cette perspective est de mettre
fin à la privatisation des
autoroutes et en attendant, de
négocier la baisse des tarifs aux
péages, qui sont excessivement
élevés et qui pèsent sur le
pouvoir d'achat des Français.
Si on n'est pas attentifs à
embarquer tout le monde, à un
moment donné, on n'avance pas.
Que pensez-vous d'une telle
proposition?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Clément
Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Madame la
présidente, mesdames et messieurs
les députés, madame Christine
Arrighi, veuillez excuser
l'absence d'Elisabeth Borne.
Nous avons une convergence, la
nécessité de changer les
comportements pour la transition
écologique.
Nous avons une divergence, c'est
que vous voulez tout faire reposer
sur la contrainte et sur
l'obligation systématique.
Ce n'est pas notre approche et ce
n'est pas l'approche la plus
efficace.
Par ailleurs, je note un certain
nombre de contradictions.
Baisser les péages et vouloir
contraindre le recours à la
voiture, c'est contradictoire.
Je ne comprends pas votre
raisonnement.
En revanche, je vais être clair
sur les 110 km/h.
Vous avez raison, les 110 km/h,
c'est bon pour le climat et le
pouvoir d'achat.
Ca permet de faire jusqu'à 20%
d'économies de carburant et 1%
d'économies d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre.
Mais prendre sa voiture pour aller
en vacances, ce n'est pas la même
chose que de la prendre tous les
jours pour aller au travail.
L'Etat demande à ses agents de
réduire leur vitesse sur
autoroute, faisant confiance à la
responsabilité et au changement
des comportements des personnes.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame Christine Arrighi?
- Christine Arrighi: Vous auriez
donc voté contre, à l'époque,
quand on a diminué la vitesse
maximale?
Quant à la privatisation, elle n'a
rapporté que 14 milliards en 2006.
- La parole est à madame Nicole
Dubré-Chirat pour le groupe
Renaissance.
- Nicole Dubré-Chirat: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
Olivier Dussopt.
Nous avons adopté la semaine
dernière le projet de loi portant
une mesure d'urgence relative au
fonctionnement du marché du
travail, en vue du plein emploi.
L'objectif est d'aller vers le
plein emploi.
Il y a un taux de chômage élevé.
Mais le chômage des jeunes a
reculé.
La première réforme en 2019
n'avait pu produire ses effets, du
fait de la crise sanitaire.
En 2021, avec le souhait des
salariés de changer d'orientation
et de se reconvertir, la France
observe des métiers en tension et
des difficultés de recrutement
dans de multiples secteurs.
En 2022, Emmanuel Macron proposait
une modification du système
d'assurance-chômage.
Un sondage publié en août 2022
montrait que 60% des Français se
disent favorables aux changements
envisagés dans le cadre de cette
réforme.
40% d'entre eux citaient comme
première explication au chômage
des indemnités trop généreuses qui
n'incitent pas au retour à
l'emploi.
Il faut que les règles
d'indemnisation soient plus
incitatives quand la situation
économique est bonne.
Et inversement, quand elle se
dégrade.
Vous avez pu définir un plan
d'action.
Pouvez-vous nous en donner le
contenu, les modalités et
l'échéancier?
Avez-vous envisagé des mesures
spécifiques pour les personnes les
plus éloignées de l'emploi qui
nécessitent un accompagnement plus
long et adapté?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
J'ai présenté aux partenaires
sociaux les règles de modulation
de l'indemnisation de
l'assurance-chômage pour tenir
compte de la conjoncture
économique et de l'état du marché
du travail.
Notre objectif est clair, c'est
d'avoir un système incitatif quand
les choses vont bien sur le marché
de l'emploi, et d'avoir un système
moins protecteur
dans le cas inverse.
Il faudra que les salaires sociaux
reprennent leurs compétences et
prolongent cet élan.
Les premiers résultats sont là.
Ils ne sont pas suffisants.
Le taux de chômage a baissé.
Nous avons encore beaucoup de
chômage mais aussi beaucoup de
tension en recrutement.
Il faut mobiliser tous les leviers
autour de l'assurance-chômage,
mais pas seulement.
Le projet de loi de finances
prévoit plus de 1,3 milliard
d'euros.
C'est 400 millions d'euros de plus
qu'en 2018.
Nous augmenterons les crédits pour
les entreprises afin d'adapter
l'accès à l'emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap.
Nous accompagnons les plus jeunes,
pour faire en sorte qu'ils
puissent trouver la voie d'une
formation qui les qualifie, ou la
voie de l'emploi.
En moyenne, 600.000 demandeurs
d'emploi avaient accès à une
formation pendant la période
d'indemnisation.
1,6 million de demandeurs d'emploi
ont été formés entre 2021 et de
demandeurs d'emploi ont été formés
entre 2021 et 2022.
Nous allons continuer sur cette
lancée pour que tout le monde
puisse être accompagné et que
l'accompagnement puisse être
adapté à chacun.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Pierre
Morel-A-L'Huissier.
- Pierre Morel-A-L'Huissier:
Merci.
Je ne sais à quel ministre il faut
s'adresser concernant la prédation
du loup.
J'ai souhaité interroger le
gouvernement ce matin.
Ni une ministre de l'Agriculture,
ni une ministre de l'Environnement
n'étaient présentes.
En contradiction totale avec ce
que j'ai entendu ce matin, le
ministre de l'Agriculture, il
avait déclaré: "Il y a un risque
de disparition de l'activité
agricole.
Je soutiens l'intérêt de
réexaminer la loi."
Il s'était engagé à faire évoluer
le statut du loup, car sa
population n'était désormais plus
en voie d'extinction.
Pourquoi ne pas soutenir la
démarche de la Suisse sur la
convention de Berne?
Il faut penser à l'indemnisation
des prédateurs, aux bergers.
Tout cela coûte beaucoup au
gouvernement.
Pourquoi les bergers ne sont
indemnisés qu'à 80%, et nous, à
100%?
Pourquoi continuer à financer des
associations pro-loups avec de
l'argent public, des associations
qui contestent tous les arrêtés
préfectoraux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Bérangère
Couillard.
- Bérangère Couillard: Merci.
Monsieur le député, sachez que le
gouvernement est mobilisé face à
la détresse des éleveurs français.
Il faut préserver les élevages,
dont le nombre ne cesse de baisser
depuis 20 ans.
Notre méthode de suivi de la
population de loups est reconnue
comme l'une des plus efficaces
d'Europe.
Elle sera maintenue au moins
jusqu'au terme du plan national
d'action, soit fin 2023.
La confiance doit être rétablie
entre les éleveurs, les chasseurs,
les élus...
Vous appelez à davantage
d'efficacité.
Le nombre de loups dont la
destruction peut être autorisée
chaque année est fixé à 19% de la
population estimée.
Pour 2022,174 ont été autorisés
car l'estimation de la population
a été revue à la hausse.
Le gouvernement décidait de
moderniser le matériel utilisé par
les nouveaux outils à hauteur de
400.000 euros.
Un déclassement ne peut être la
solution à court terme, car il est
peu vraisemblable.
Il faudrait que l'espèce soit
parfaitement restaurée et que la
décision soit prise à l'unanimité
des pays.
Si le loup se trouvait déclassé,
il faudrait une gestion avec des
quotas.
La priorité du gouvernement est de
faciliter les mesures de
protection, notamment les plus
proches des élevages, et
d'améliorer les modalités
d'accompagnement des agriculteurs.
C'est indispensable dans les
territoires comme la Lozère.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Monsieur Pierre
Morel-A-L'Huissier?
- Pierre Morel-A-L'Huissier:
11.000 ovins sont morts, 237
bovins.
On continue à ne pas regarder la
réalité.
Venez voir les éleveurs, écoutez
les éleveurs.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Nadège
Abomangoli.
- Nadège Abomangoli: Madame la
présidente, mes chers collègues,
"j'aimais mon métier mais j'ai
arrêté.
Il ne me permettait pas de vivre
dignement."
C'est un témoignage d'une AESH
dans Ouest-France.
Cette année encore, de nombreux
enfants voient le déficit de
l'accompagnement.
Certains sont déscolarisés.
Le gouvernement ne fait rien, ou
peu pour les AESH.
A chaque rentrée, vous abordez
benoîtement ce phénomène.
A chaque rentrée, il manque des
aides AESH.
C'est un emploi payé en moyenne
800 euros par mois.
Il y a peu de formation et pas
d'intégration à la communauté
éducative.
Le métier n'est pas attractif et
pas reconnu.
Le marché des AESH privés est en
plein essor.
Il détruit l'école républicaine et
l'égalité des droits.
Je veux une proposition de loi qui
revendique la création d'un poste
de fonctionnaire pour les AESH,
pour une meilleure rémunération
avec 24 heures de travail, payé à
temps plein.
Je veux des formations tout au
long de la carrière, un parcours
professionnel avec mobilité.
Il faut créer un statut de
fonctionnaire.
C'est une mission fonctionnaire et
pérenne qui exige des compétences
spécifiques.
Pourtant, en commission, la
minorité prudentielle a choisi de
tourner le dos aux AESH.
Le gouvernement a proposé un
hypothétique CDI au bout de trois
ans.
C'est la moyenne d'ancienneté dans
la profession.
Vous leur demandez d'étendre leur
mission, comme si ce n'était pas
assez.
Monsieur le ministre, quand
cesserez-vous de voir les AESH de
cette façon?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Pap
Ndiaye.
- Pap Ndiaye: Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, madame la
députée Abomangoli, la proposition
que vous faites de création d'un
corps de fonctionnaire a le goût
du progrès, l'apparence, mais elle
n'en a pas la réalité.
Vous voulez créer un corps de
fonctionnaires et dans votre idée,
il s'agirait d'un corps de
fonctionnaires de catégorie B.
Il faudrait pour cela le
baccalauréat.
Seuls 20% des AESH ont le
Cela empêcherait de nombreuses
personnes d'accéder à ce métier.
Ensuite, pour entrer dans la
fonction publique, il faut avoir
la citoyenneté française.
Il y a des AESH qui n'ont pas la
nationalité française.
Vous les excluez.
Beau progrès, belle avancée!
Merci pour eux.
Ce que nous faisons, c'est, avec
le travail de ces groupes, que
nous augmentons les...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: S'il vous
plaît!
- Pap Ndiaye: Nous allons
augmenter les AESH l'année
prochaine.
Nous allons créer 4000 postes
supplémentaires et nous favorisons
le passage en CDI au bout de trois
ans.
Voilà ce que nous réalisons
concrètement, plutôt que des
fausses promesses qui
n'aboutissent qu'à exclure une
partie des personnels AESH du
fameux corps de fonctionnaires
dont vous rêvez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame Abomangoli, cinq secondes.
- Nadège Abomangoli: Tous les
obstacles que vous énumérez
peuvent être dans la fonction
publique.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La séance est suspendue.
Nous reprendrons sous le vote
solennel.